هي خطوه للوراء او على الاقل رجوع الى ما
خلف الكواليس ينوي الامير هاري وزوجته
ميغا اتخاذها فذوق وذوق قررت تولي ادوار
بعيده عن انظار الجمهور اي التوقف عن
كتابه الكتب وصنع الافلام الوثائقيه
والجلوس لاجراء المقابلات لمهاجمه افراد
العائله المالكه مطلعون زعموا بان الخطوه
تاتي بعد فراغ جعبه الزوجين من اي شيء
ليقولوه فيما ردها اخرون لدخول يوم دائره
السخريه بلا هوادا فرغبت الزوجين
بالخصوصيه تتناقض وفق صحف بريطانيه مع
وجودهما الدائم على منصات التلفزه وصنفتها
بمحاولات متكرره للفت النظر فيما عزت جهات
اخرى ابتعادهما عن الاضواء لصلح قد يلوح
بالافق بين هاري وعائلته يذكر ان ذوقه
وذوقه عن الحياه في العائله المالكه قبل
ثلاث سنوات وهاجما خلالها باستمرار افراد
هذه العائله سواء تلفزيونيا او في كتابه
في كتاب هاري سبير الذي من ضمنه ملابسات
وظروف تخليه عن واجباته الملكيه اذا دوق
وصف ايضا صمت عائلته تجاه الهجوم الاعلامي
عليه بالخيانه متهمه اياهم بتسريب خططه
لانتقال للعيش في الولايات المتحده اما
عنصريه العائله المالكه فكانت احدى شكاوى
زوجته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات